yeah I started to be interested in
architecture and design when I was 14
years old which is pretty pretty early
in life and then I start to look at
architectural magazines and then
eventually went to school of
architecture to you know and but one of
the things I learned very early is that
the NOC eaten anything from the spoon to
the city that was a famous phrase by
other floors in his architects you know
the turn of the century the other simply
and I was fascinated by that idea and
then I've seen it that is true and a
great actors like lowes and Hoffman from
Vienna again we're doing these kind of
things and since I was born and raised
in Milan architects in Milan they were
also doing all kind of things you know
they were designing buildings and
furniture and interiors and exhibitions
and so on then I had a share an
apartment with Max uber famous graphic
designer from Switzerland and swollen
graphic design and I got full in love
with graphic design and so I was doing
the whole name again from graphics to
architecture so I built a house at one
point for a client and then I did the
exhibitions and then I start to do
products and you know so that's that
that's the way I started and I like it
to try all the time at that time try
different materials different
experiences was eager to try all kind of
things you know I suppose that attitude
hasn't left me after a long long life of
design any of you know so that's how I
got interested in architecture and
design and naturally since I was very
curious about the protagonist of the
modern movement in Europe at the time by
the time they got to at the University
of architecture
that means about 20 years old I already
met personally all the major architects
in Europe from the Corbusier to you name
it all the others and the country by
country and which was very exciting you
know I was kind of a groupie he will say
no you know and and of course i was
reading all the books about them and
about what i had to say and that gave me
the critical strength or the critical
background you know to to approach
architecture and design